add a Karen come up to me after the show
yeah and she got all up in my face and
she goes you know that story you told
about the Uber driver was racist and I
said what part about that was racist she
goes how do you know he was Mexican
and I said um
I'll tell you how I know he was Mexican
Karen he had a portrait of the Last
Supper airbrushed on his tailgate
that's how the [__] I know he was
Mexican Karen
you coming at the wrong one Karen
I happen to be a fan of airbrush
tailgates
and only Mexicans are keeping them alive
and I would simply like to say gracias
okay
I live right here too I've seen some
beautiful Jesus pieces in traffic all
around Southern California so maybe
you're the racist Karen clearly you've
never been to San Bernardino
foreign
[Applause]